we'll open these that's loud we'll we'll
open the executive session on House Bill
453 representative Berry is recognized
for a motion uh yes sir uh I moved uh
450 to be in speed into legislate
so say what now inexpedient to legislate
I'm I'm thinking about lunch
oh that's what we're doing yes okay we
are doing Ito fair enough is there a
second I'll second
I feel like I missed a conversation but
is there a discussion
yes I would like to speak on on this go
ahead
uh
I am in favor of itl even though my name
is one of the sponsors on this bill uh
when when you get new information in
life do you stay with the first opinion
you had or do you change your opinion
well I have changed my opinion based on
the fact that uh
the folded ballots can still be counted
accurately with current electronic
ballot counting machines
when they are used within
um
when they're used within accordance of
state law and good practices
and I also learned that
um the new electronic ballot counting
machines that are being tested
can solve some of all of the problems
that we're trying to solve with this
legislation so
that is coming on they're coming online
right now at this point and maybe within
the next three or four years most
communities will be using them
so uh with that that's why I have
the concerns about in expedient to
legislate other ones were the large
envelopes that I was very concerned that
would be left unattended at apartment
complexes the way packages sometimes are
I I wouldn't want that problem so more
problems just seemed to pop up and and
the testimony that we heard and in my
conversations with Secretary of State
okay further discussion
thank you Mr chair so um I've talked to
the people in my town when it comes to
receiving folded ballots and they
actually have to place it uh for hand
count after so it does take more time
the machines kick them out
um and um I just I think it's worth um
not having them folded when they are
sent
it does create problems and keeps people
there longer as well and ballots aren't
being read by the machine properly
thank you
okey-dokey the motion is inexperienced
to legislate on House Bill 453 the clerk
will call the role please representative
Berry yes
representative prudhome O'Brien yes
representative Bohm yes
representative qualey yes
Representative inkerberg no
representative Burnham
no
representative Kennedy
yes
representative weary yes
yes representative wood
yes
representative Lane yes
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative warehead
representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes
and representative Palmer yes
18 years and two Nays
does somebody want to move consent then
I'll move it to the consent calendar
what's up will representative Brian be
doing the report
yes I'd be happy to do that awesome
already
that closes the executive session on
House Bill 453 sorry to interrupt your
lunch